good afternoon everyone I'm tallest I'm
director of the Center for the Arts
welcome to special to Spinelli Papua who
is visiting us from CMU's center campus
where she's a lecture and liberal and
social sciences after holding several
prestigious postdoctoral fellowship see
preceding years as a melon postdoctoral
fellow at UCLA and a research fellow at
the Institute for Advanced Study Berlin
in the english translation of that that
fine institution sonali is a cultural
anthropologist she's work expensively in
Egypt and she has spent a great deal of
time there especially working on youth
culture theater and arts programs she
has worked also as a culture cultural
journalist for Allah from weekly in
Cairo and so thanks to all of you for
coming today thanks to sonali TOA and to
the co-sponsors of this event which
includes CMU Qatar Northwestern
University Qatar and Cardinals
Department of History so a situation in
Egypt is obviously one that's been on my
mind a great deal on all of your minds a
great deal and my reaction and perhaps
yours to Egypt as a somebody who doesn't
know a lot about Egypt tends to
oscillate between what i would call
uninformed pessimism and naive optimism
uninformed pessimism because i think is
a tendency to take it as natural or as
it given the country like say Tunisia or
Egypt should be subject to despotic rule
that rulers like him bark-like Hosni
Mubarak will be around as long as their
life's been permitted perhaps handing
off eventually to another desk bot
typically a son but preserving a system
basically intact and that kind of
uninformed pessimism i think has been
challenged by recent events but so has
and maybe what were less aware of us is
is the perils of naive optimism as we
observe these events and that i would
say is the notion that this trans
national mobilization may be understood
simply in terms of the new media as i
quote facebook revolution as we've been
described or Twitter revolution and in
so doing I think there are some
important aspect of
we capture their others that we miss we
can use means namely the media with
motive and perhaps mistake the beginning
of something for an ending and this kind
of perspective also belies the fact that
while husband Mubarak and political
allies may be gone of course the
military remains along with a host of
other entities and figures that along
with the upper echelon of the military
have long and long been heavily invested
in a kind of authoritarian system the
kind of crony capitalism that have
characterized this regime and so might
have a deep stake in at least trying to
maintain that system even if in a
different management so ensure much
remains to be seen much remains to be
done and so here today as a means to
trying to begin to understand all of
this or track it more more insightfully
we have suddenly Paula's visit which I
think has a great deal to offer all of
us it was interesting that over the last
couple weeks I've had all kinds of
congratulations from people wow it's so
great that you're responding to events
in Egypt so quickly arranging at the top
it's so appropriate so on target wow I
never happens but of course this is
entirely serendipitous we've ish planks
and always visit for I think at least
three months or four months even and
this is just happened to coincide
in Egypt I was impressed by sonali's
work as she's a PhD in cultural
anthropology in Columbia University as i
mentioned before she stays do youth
culture in cairo particularly focused on
performance drama and self-help and the
politics of performance in relationship
to egypt's governing neoliberal economic
and political order she has several
forthcoming publications inestimable
journals with titles like personalizing
development parts of selfless in
neoliberal egypt and acting up youth in
the politics of performance in Egypt and
in fact the talk she was initially
planning to give today before
everything's have happened in Egypt was
going to be entitled active identity
youth theatre drama therapy and
globalized citizenship in Egypt but as
events have transpired we've been in
touch in every few days the tightening
of a subject has changed she's
completely transformed her talk now to
not only to engage with her prior work
and interests but to relate them to the
current situation a situation that is of
course very much still in the process
for all of us I think this fortuitous
collision of sonali's deep experience in
Cairo and our interest in such topics as
youth politics performance and
neoliberalism makes her an ideal
candidate to cure us pack perhaps of
both are uninformed pessimism and naive
optimism moving us in the process I hope
towards something like informed
hopefulness but cautious hopefully her
talk today is entitled from alienation
to revolution youth and the performance
of citizenship in Egypt
thanks very much Paul thanks for coming
everyone on a busy weekday so I'm going
to jump right in on the evening of
februari 7th Twitter in Egypt was abuzz
with anxiety about the delayed release
of wild whore named who had disappeared
12 12 days ago the 30 year old Egyptian
worked in Dubai as a marketing executive
for Google and his arrest by secret
police revealed that he was also a
political activist both his employer and
his activist friends brought pressure on
the embattled Egyptian government to
release him and later that evening her
name reappeared on Twitter announced his
freedom and went on Egypt's Prime
late-night talk show the weary young man
revealed to the show's host Mona lesli
that he had been the anonymous
administrator of the facebook page
calling for the protest would snowboard
into a revolution the page we are all
hell inside was named after a young
internet cafe owner from Alexandria
killed last June by police after he
videotapes their corrupt practices and
now her name's own treatment at the
hands of secret police galvanised not
just young activists but a nationwide
television audience how did he become an
icon Wael Ghonim did not act the part of
a revolutionary he began his interview
with an earnest apology for the lives
lost when Street protesters clashed with
central security police yet as an
everyman example of the industrial
citizen by day and activists by night
her name focused attention on identity
politics in the broad Egyptian
generation described as youth who
channeled alienation into alternative
nationalism these middle-class
professionals unemployed internet cafe
dwellers bloggers dramatists and
teachers had come of age since the 1990s
when Egypt's state institutions cut
employment in a program of neoliberal
privatisation forced to cobble together
part-time jobs and often unable to marry
or live independently many in this
generation found their identity outside
of professional roles my talk today
follows the paths of young Egyptians
who used critical theatre personal
development programs and drama therapy
to form characters representing their
quests for identity they used
performance variously to dramatize
develop and heal a fractured self the
performance genres that I will sample
today stage different politics including
theater by leftist youth troops and
self-help workshops for improving
performance in a neoliberal economy yet
I will argue that performance is a
central aspect of these varied efforts
at claiming identity through imaginative
embodiment Egyptian youth who used
performance to stage difference from
tropes of identity in an earlier
generation did so not in order to dis
identify with the idea of the citizen
but to generate new norms of citizenship
the figure of the youth in these
performance genres typically embodied
the struggles of the generation
abandoned by state institutions and
traced their parts of alternative social
participation like konam they pointed an
accusing finger at a corrupt system that
stymied their future but in performing
alternative scenarios and as if roles
these youth did not been their hopes for
reform on the establishment in a
conventional political sense instead
both activist and conformist youths
looked to arts of the self appropriating
neoliberal ideologies of self-help often
against the grain in order to rehearse
acts of proper citizenship I would like
to share with you today two plays staged
in 2004 by independent troops in Cairo
on the topic of satellite television and
globalization scenes from self-help
programs and finally a drama therapy
workshop in which young professionals
learned to stage psychological conflict
when I completed this research in 2009
the notion that alternative youth
culture would culminate in a revolution
was only a dream albeit one drummed
widely indeed the plot of the first play
that I will discuss featured political
demonstrations yet I will read the turn
from youthful alienation to revolution
not as a historical progression but as
an iteration offering some thoughts on
the revolution as a uniquely successful
performative event
prefigured in earlier performances the
use of the suffering body to stage
social contradictions and a theatre to
give alienation a social narrative
eventually resonated from stage and
studio to street and square it is this
recuperation of experience through
performance that forms my analytic so
instead of seeing embodiment as the
means of expressing what cannot be
accommodated within discourse or speech
I will examine how embodied performance
gives form to fragments of experience in
analyzing theater and therapy I seek to
trace then how many Gyptians transforms
the category of youth to which their
tenuous social adulthood could find them
into a trope for struggles for
citizenship so my first section is
called talking back to the screen Canada
sorry with a television producer by day
and a socialist activist at heart he was
also the founder of one of kairos oldest
independent theater troupes established
when he was a student at Carroll
University's Faculty of Law the troupe
was named haraka meaning movement in
both the embodied and the political
sense as the halacha grew from a
university troupe into a stalwart of the
independent theatre movement launched in
1990 its place shifted from
expressionist drama to a popular
political comedy nevertheless had said
the directing and acting in his own
place quote belong to my vision in a way
that his work as a television producer
did not even as he was gaining
recognition for his cinnamon rolls
carrot continue to devote himself to
theatre other haruka troupe members were
also media professionals and television
actors their loyalty to the critical
theatre of their University days
reflected in reverse the attachment of
younger dramatists who were unemployed
these youth who graduated 10 years later
maintained the university troops and
held on to the arc that they loved as a
haven from the pressures of a grim
search for employment claridon as
colleagues meanwhile made a living as
media professionals but gained little
job satisfaction for Halid in particular
theater provided a creative space for
his political thought at the
card-carrying socialist he had often
organized strikes and demonstrations
at the lawyers and the actors syndicates
in Cairo most recently he had
participated with Haruka troop members
in the massive anti-war protests in
kairos universities in main squares that
accompanied the invasion of iraq in
march two thousand and three it was at
these protests had it told me that the
idea of his 2004 play messing with the
mind was born the play was based on
improvisation initially had it and said
his assistant both producers at
state-owned a television developed a
script about the fabrications of arab
television in the satellite age with the
title a lab for the mare messing with
the mind like many in the independent
theatre world the chanukah dramatists
were critical of Arab satellite
television and the globalization
represented by its advertisements for
consumer goods on the one hand and it's
entertainment programming on the other
while music videos and satellite
channels such as the saudi-owned rotana
showed Arab youths engaging in luxurious
courtships many young kyrene struggled
to find work and Mary often they
channeled their enforced leisure into
making art at the long cafeteria of
kairos henagar theater established by
the Ministry of Culture in 1988 or the
nearby outdoor cafe groups of young men
and women gathered at tables from the
afternoon onward talking over tea and
cigarettes about ideas for place they
were regularly visited by set and
costume designers or theater critics who
also frequented these cafes often the
discussion with Center on a translated
play or a novel that one of the group
wanted to adapt for the stage but I
never heard talk of adapting a play from
the Arab dramatic literature that was
the job of state theaters like the
National the avant-garde and the Salam
the youth troops who considered the
henager their home usually felt
alienated from the writings of older
playwrights however socially critical
they had been their own generations
concerns were very different and so they
improvised upon contemporary social
themes and adapted translated works to
tell their stories in a fresh dramatic
language with the 2004 play messing with
the mind the hidaka troops thought a
wider audience for its work then its
usual constituency of youth
and artists as popular sentiment against
the Iraq war grew in Cairo the troops or
particular opportunity for its style of
political cabaret and cabaret sese had a
post-performance statement about the
play emphasized that he was bringing new
politics to the familiar genre coach I
called for the troupe to begin from the
street where at the first protest of the
attack on Iraq we raised up the emblem
of the troupe and gathered to go to the
protest then we got together afterwards
to discuss it emphasizing that the play
group out of the political conscience of
troop members Khaled went on to say that
it was a labor of love which the troupe
developed without knowing if it would
ever be staged they did find a producer
the head of the hanniger theater dr.
Hoda Wesley recognized she had a hit on
her hands with the first aunty Eric war
drama in Egypt and she gave the troupe a
large production budget and a rehearsal
space both of which were used to expand
the play into a sizable ensemble drama
nevertheless her lid drew upon his usual
activist methods to advertise the play
at the cairo international book fair
held in late january troupe members
distributed Flyers as if to a protest
much the Flyers read quote we want to
say no to american occupation corruption
capitalist globalization media fakery
and the israeli occupation so come and
see the show and add your voice to ours
and quote framing the tendons of the
players participation in political and
economic protest hallett emphasized the
performative force of life theater in
contrast to the television productions
which the play would critique at the
final dress rehearsal attended by
government censors he sent out an
invitation by text message and got about
a hundred acquaintances to attend so
they could serve as witnesses to any
demands for cuts the ploy worked and the
script was approved in full at the place
opening I waited outside the theater
doors with a crowd that milled
throughout the long cafeteria and then a
group of actors burstyn wearing the
camouflage attire of US Marines and
waiting fake guns they herded audience
members into the hall with loudly barked
orders occasional shoves and the
menacing pop of air guns this tactile
assault brought home the war the war
viscerally
and then it was made televisual cameras
filmed our entry into the theater and
projected it onto a giant on stage
screen with background music a producer
on stage shouted instructions and went
to applaud and how to behave warning
don't forget we're on the air the before
space had been transformed into an Arab
satellite television studio during the
filming of a talk show the place
audience was invited both to experience
the wartime objection of Iraqis and to
become experiential II aware of its own
participation in the new trance Arab
media that conveyed both war and
entertainment the fictional talk show in
display titled wash Tunis was hosted by
a classic Egyptian television presenter
with bleached blond hair and a
flirtatious manner Madame nadia was
however a tyrant off-screen the dramatic
expose of messing with the mind was
performed by alternating between the
Arab world seen on television and its
unsavory backstage and nadia was an icon
of the deception indicated in the place
title quote she's always hiding her age
and pretends to be the opposite of
everything she is had it explained she
is the regime and the system not just a
symbol Nadia's opposite number was an
American general called Tom Fox a guest
on the current episode of the show the
director Khaled himself played the
general with comic Flair as a collage of
stereotypes of Americans on television
he greeted the audience with a hip-hop
song about how much he loved Egypt
performing both an endearing naivete and
macho body language the banter between
Nadia and Fox emblems of the two regimes
engaged in a strategic alliance showed
up the generals misunderstanding of
Egypt Fox look Nadia Arab youth are deep
in my heart fine youth I asked myself
what do our abuse want what do they want
they want a bride aroosa Nadia oh my
goodness so general foxx if we say that
the young Arab men does want to bride
what can folks to Fox Oh Fox can do
plenty moments later Fox brings on what
he understood to be in arusha are
pre-empting the word by the other
meaning a doll he presents a life-size
low-priced mannequin as his answer to
the crisis of marriage in Egypt due to
unemployment as pointed as the satire of
the misguided American was the critique
of Egyptian
scott in the spell of Arab satellite TV
was shabbos still Madame Nadia's next
guest is a college student named Ashley
off who professes to be a lifelong fan
of the show I chef studies business
significantly and his westernized accent
and hipster necklace mark him as a use
of the neoliberal era if this weren't
enough he vigorously repeats Nadia's
homily on how youths must help
themselves and not expect the government
to be their mother I should for
understanding of the new liberalism is
comically twisted and the questions of
the talk show host revealed that he's in
a relationship with a married woman
Nadia's horrified wrestles him down and
covers his mouth she may not be the
mother state but she is quick to lay
down the law I shaft farcical story
offers commentary on how the mainstream
media in Egypt suppress the voices of
youth but it's also an unfolding drama
of how an older generation led youth
like him astray Ashraf's immorality does
not owe to satellite television as we
shall see but is an inheritance from his
father in this era of participatory
television the talk show hosts effort at
censorship is thwarted as Ashraf's lover
intisar calls into the show with the
scandalous revelation that he stole her
money but the next caller assured father
defends his actions in front of God
Almighty ir Justin affirmed that a chef
is a model son who thought not of
himself but of his needy family I know
about those 5,000 pounds of the sisters
talking about they're in my pocket just
now and then we find that intisar was
also following family tradition with her
scampers relationship in an interview
she mentions that her mother was quote
clever and bishops and father's only
capital end quote as seen from her
childhood plays out at the back and we
see her mother going to work as a
prostitute where the Gulf Arab tourists
visiting for the summer and the mother
is played by the same actress who does
Madame Nadia this audacious reference to
a social phenomenon that had for years
been an open secret links the supposed
corruption of the nation's youth to a
broader decline that is the consequence
of economic globalization satellite
television talk shows conveniently
airbrush out such details but later in
the play the reality of war birth
through its deceptions dramatizing the
objection of the
Arab nation between the beneath the
cheerful images on television screens
messing with the mind was a huge hit in
Cairo and Alexandria tapping into the
zeitgeist and uniting theater critics in
a rare consensus taking up the popular
topic of the Iraq war the troop shifted
the focus of its critique to social
corruption within Egypt the struggles of
youth enacted in the play indexed larger
conflicts and unresolved questions on
how to be an ethical citizen when
economic disparity intertwined with the
corruption of social norms in the course
of the 3-hour dramatic narrative iraq
began a trope for troubles closer to
home the carnivalesque encounter of
egyptian television presenters
starstruck use and American generals was
significantly punctuated with choruses
of protest songs that began with the
ironic greeting good morning Egypt next
section is called youth media and a
third space in the rousing conclusion to
messing with the mind the halaqa troupe
affirmed the theater was a trope for the
kind of embodied political action that
was needed to break through the
reception's of official media but
another play that opened in Cairo just a
week later showed that the media worlds
of Egyptian youth offered a third space
for alternative kinds of embodied action
the marbeth troops clay mother I want to
be a millionaire used a smaller theater
to stage more intimate media worlds the
33 year old director Amidala thought was
a graduate of the American University in
Cairo and of the soft bone and since his
trilingual networking had brought
funding for the play from European
sources primarily the berliner
festspiele ax he could afford to stage
it without tickets and to experiment
with avant-garde techniques less
familiar to egyptian theater goers quote
it is a play about this generation its
hopes and concerns Hamid said he created
a psychological drama about youth
immersed in televisual worlds by
watching Arab talent contests like super
star which is like American Idol and
improvising on the characters of
would-be pop idols perform they're like
messing with the mind this play used an
on-stage screen to separate television
reality from its embodied counterpart
however its plot and its form both
showed that youth did not just use media
they inhabited media was Adam the
described mother I want to be a milliner
as a play made like a film it was set on
a vertical stage mimicking a screen
different parts of which were lit for
each scene here the world of the
television contest dominated the story
for several scenes until the protagonist
appeared he was the television obsessed
youth unable to perform sitting silently
with his dinner or repeating wrote
lessons at school while the singers
peacocking on television could hope to
realize their dreams the contrast
between television and the mundane lives
of Egyptian youth is marked in display
by the use of colors music and
contrasting verbal registers of
infantile repetition as in the school
scene and song yet these short scenes
are as flat as a screen they do not
develop narratives no to their
characters unfold it is when hacen
begins the chat relationship with a
woman in another part of the set that
the play develops a temporal rhythm they
speak first on the phone a listless
conversation about their uneventful
lives but then hacen acquires a
fictitious avatar as if in an Internet
chat room excuse me a minute and his
story begins to move forward
rootstown
so the woman's the woman is on top of
the screen and he's below here we see
hustling assumed the persona of the
fairytale hero shattered Hassan in order
to be a romantic hero just as the
aspiring stars of the thinning contest
did things with words he too uses the
performative possibilities of media to
do what he cannot do when acting as
himself this is among few dialogues in a
play dominated by monologues Hassan's
online persona actively navigates a
third social space between the talent
contest and his dull life in a quest
that echoes that eras avatar the
adventurous folk hero shatter Hassan
eventually this persona crumbles when
his flirtatious interlocutor decides to
stop playing the game and turns
religious the disconnect between
Hassan's media persona and embodied self
becomes especially visible in a scene of
therapy where he passes a probe over his
body to find out what's wrong with him
the figure of a disembodied hero playing
multiple roles was somewhat ahead of its
time and the play ended with an
explosion into madness Hassan becomes
delusional believes he has won the
talent contest and goes out to deliver a
victory performance that turns into an
act of self violence
when he's singing a song over here you
get the sense of the subtitles it's the
same song though the contestants were
singing
okay so i'll give you the soundtrack so
he becomes delusional and this lack of
me drops down
I'm talking about how he hates Egyptians
and hates himself
anyway this run despite this cautionary
ending mother to be a millionaire was
remarkable for locating performance
within the media world who swatted adult
lives were otherwise isolated and dreary
here a depressed young man could cast
aside the mechanical repetitions of
school and home escape the frustrations
of walk watching a lucky few win on
satellite television and write his own
story he could perform an anticipation
of a future however illusory indeed new
media proved over the ensuing years to
be a more effective third space for
youth to act then the policed space of
political demonstrations in which a
committed few continued to venture taken
together these plays about satellite
television by theatre troupes minimally
linked to stations can be seen as
narratives of the alternative public
sphere which independent cultural
producers were seeking to create between
the hierarchies and ideologies of state
institutions and the consumer culture of
Arab satellite television lay the ground
of this urban youth culture the
dramatists who sought to establish
themselves as cultural producers here
emphasize their belonging in a
generational community in a way that was
uncommon for a Bongard dramatists in
other contexts they presented their
performances as examples of authentic
generational voices outside the
manipulation of state and transnational
media ideology the fragments of
television programming that formed the
basis for these two plays were used to
show that youth felt alienated from them
more at home in the theater or on the
internet they rehearsed roles here that
pointed to a future in which more
habitable forms of identity will be
realized next section is called
neoliberalism and self-help as media and
economic globalization proceeded apace
young Egyptians also began to
participate in programs that used the
means of performance more functionally
to inhabit roles in a changing economy
when i returned to cairo in 2007 i found
a number of dramatist friends working as
self-help trainers at schools NGOs and
private cultural centers they told
acting methods including improvisation
to college graduate seeking professional
skills as well as the children whose
middle class there
wanted to improve their social skills
all of this occurred in a changing
cultural landscape where the growing
prominence of private cultural
institutions and a broad movement for
personal development at van may alba
sharia was bringing dominant notions of
culture closer to those of education the
pedagogical use of theater and self-help
programs thus echoed a wider trend in
self making as a creative exercise and
the use of artistic techniques toward
arts of the self in a neoliberal era
marked by the retreat of state cultural
and educational institutions while
independent theater troupe used
performance to embody fishers and
contemporary identity discourse personal
development programs drew on acting
techniques toward rehearsing new norms
in professional and social roles the
college students who attended these
programs at kairos biggest youths
cultural center the sake of the sowwie
known as the Sakia thrust tidally and
walked purposefully to the lecture halls
with none of the lounging and chatting
seen at the henegar heels culture was a
less liminal concept certainly for these
middle-class youth who sought to build
qualifications and compete in the
neoliberal job market when I asked the
24 year old editor of Zacchaeus magazine
what made it a cultural magazine she
turned the question back at me what is
culture does it have to do only with the
Arts there's also a strong relationship
to society we present you with
information and knowledge and quote thus
the papers are clear this magazine
specialized in articles on young role
models book ended with opinion columns
by the center's businessman founder who
by the way has just become the minister
of culture in personal development
workshops hosted at this Cultural Center
the pedagogical discourse of self-help
chicon performative dimensions as
participants learned how to emulate role
models I transpose homie Baba's concept
sorry I transpose homie Baba's concept
of the pedagogical and performative
bowls of national identity formation to
these workshops and show their
conflation as performative pedagogy
gained in popularity while public
education failed to keep pace with the
neoliberal economy self-help had become
a culture
simply a set of individual initiatives
and a host of aesthetic means including
performance created of symbols the
suckiest founder muhammad aslam was the
son of a former minister of culture and
the owner of an advertising agency he
named the center after his late father
while formulating a culturing mission of
the fief in a distinctively contemporary
vein sowwy used his advertising skills
to create social campaigns with
eye-catching posters and disseminate the
Center's cultural discourse through a
high-quality magazine as well as an
internet radio station the performance
schedule at the center exemplified a
sowwies businesslike policies theater
troupes and bands could rent a hall for
a fee and a portion of the ticket sales
rather than being selected by an
artistic committee as at state theaters
this policy was widely derided by Kairos
arts intelligentsia who considered the
cercle a second-rate institution but it
illuminated a crucial aspect of
neoliberal culture in Cairo that
everyone could be a cultural producer
arts of the self now bore a contentious
and contingent relation with producers
of the more traditional arts here at the
sakya music and theater were part of the
entertainment programming while
educational workshops were taught by
self-help trainers and businesspeople
meanwhile at schools NGOs and acting
studios dramatists offered courses in
self presentation and improvisation
skills I will examine the former
programs and compared them with others
using embodied techniques to ask how
performance and pedagogy complemented
each other as youth cultural programs
began to focus on personal ethics on a
summer evening in 2009 i sat near the
front of a lecture hall of the south
here with about a hundred young women
orland in your head scars while the men
settled into chairs across the aisle we
were at a weekly meeting of the youth
group Martin together and unlike the
informal gatherings usually implied by
that term this meeting was led by a
lecturer in suit and tie who set up his
laptop on stage he began with a
motivational speech for job seeking use
quote you can sit in a cafe and complain
or you can do something constructive
moreover he emphasized that work was a
form of ethical social Potter
station quote I should ask myself how
can i help my nation and my religion
with another refrain after an
announcement for volunteers needed by
the islamic social service organizations
rossella the lecturer went on to drill
the participants in gmat questions for
three rigorous hours the mine website
listed brief bios of successful
graduates and featured a fictional
dialogue between a new member and a more
seasoned one cook I don't seem to have a
goal in life or know how to define what
I want came the question and the older
member responded quote seek your goal
diligently and persistently like our
master Abraham man guides you one day a
week for the rest you must go to other
places to learn and gain experience man
has no link to a particular
specialization you are the only person
who can define your own goals the
motivational language with a religious
overtone framed the group's mission as
that of teaching youth ethical forms of
identity crucially such forms of
identity depended not on professional
achievements but on first and abilities
developed through training the idea that
rehearsal for professional roles traced
a path to success was reiterated in
another program at the sakya called work
is worship allah me labeda a lively
corporate executive in her 40s call
dream let each session which featured
simulated encounters between job seeking
use and corporate employers or
presentations by successful young
professionals reen said that she
elicited the concerns of participants
and thought of ways to resolve them in
today's session which she responded to
several young women who worried that
multinational corporations would
discriminate against them for wearing a
headscarf by bringing in what she called
a model from society who made an effort
and succeeded Lamia was a mahadji ba
english literature graduate who had
taught herself about business for
various internships and eventually got a
permanent job at one of the companies
impressed by her eagerness to learn this
flesh and blood embodiment of an
entrepreneurial young woman with a
strong work ethic in contrast to the
rather abstract ideas of the man website
brought together the abstract
performance skills taught at personal
development workshops and their efficacy
or the elocution
rien / locution arey force of role
models Lamia had educated herself at
every available opportunity and she had
succeeded in the corporate world without
fitting the elite bilingual profile the
dream represented the diverse workshops
of the self-help movement commonly
called at the me Alba Sharia share the
faith and rehearsal as a productive
activity whether this meant volunteering
professional training or improvisation
workshops speakers at each of the youth
programs used a positive language of
embodiment encouraging youth to rehearse
and practice until they became what they
sought to be this language resonated
with discourse on south making within
egypt's islamic piety movement and also
with the neoliberal discourse on
education as investment that michel
foucault has called a theory of human
capital of course personal development
training was a highly speculative
investment Hugh youth who undertook it
had any clear evidence of returns indeed
with so little certainty about
professional futures in Egypt all
educational investments required a leap
of faith the training workshops taught
youths self-reliance and spawned a
variety of volunteer movement that
echoed the work of Islamic social
organizations like the one you see here
yet these self-help workshops were
person-centered in a way that gave
little space to discussions of social
conflict or differences in cultural
capital those differences emerged in a
theatre program for child labourers
which I discussed elsewhere that's the
middle-class kyrene youth preparing for
mainstream professional careers there
were few social avenues in which to
articulate conflict psychotherapy
provided one such avenue consonant with
the person-centered economic ideology in
this left section i will look at drama
therapy workshops and ask how the notion
of conflict as a psychological process
in neoliberal development discourse
generated cultural forms in which
performance remained a useful means of
problematizing the embodiment of
citizenship the section is called
therapy culture the character of the
depressive use at a therapy session in
the play mother I want to be a
millionaire brought a widely
acknowledged phenomenon into the
dramatic repertoire the word depression
used often interchangeably with
frustration was regularly heard in
conversations among those who spend
their
employed hours cafes downtown at arts
venues increasingly young professionals
in Cairo also turned to therapeutic
practices like yoga and courses in the
arts tucked away in a leafy corner of
the middle class Cairo neighborhood
mohandeseen the Actors Studio was a
thriving venue for therapy through drama
from six to nine each evening the studio
founded by the film star Mohamed Hamidah
hosted classes in an eight-month acting
program many of those who attended the
program did not plan acting careers
however there were journalists office
workers and amateur actors who came to
the studio between work and home it's
something I do for myself one journalist
told me in this setting unlike at the
personal development workshops people
spoke of a weak self in need of a safe
haven I argue that participants in the
drama therapy workshops developed an
alternative social discourse of
personhood through group exercises in
enacting this vulnerable itself in a
darkened studio where soulful music
formed an auditory background they left
behind their professional boys and
performed relaxation exercises group
therapy and dramatic scenes that staged
particular emotions the methodical
reversal of self making in the
preparatory exercises marked the
performances of expressions of an
interior consciousness and the very
space of the studio signified something
like an urban unconscious drama therapy
contained within this interior space
social conflicts that also played out in
the theater yet by using the embodied
and narrative techniques of theater the
workshop also generated identifiable
characters indeed the actor studio had
hosted improvisations that turned into a
successful film about youthful
alienation alcott virag spare time I'd
like to share with you two scenes
intended for therapy and analyze how
these generated dramatic roles that were
both therapeutic and symbolic of the
vulnerable cells the 30 year old
instructor Sammy had been a long time
stage actor before turning to what he
called psycho drama I want to know you
from the inside he told the students
even if you lie to yourself outside it
is forbidden to lie here the first
person whom you face here is yourself
you must feel
I am NOT concerned that you should be an
artist the actors began class by taking
up the posture of ice statues that melt
and stand up again they followed
instructions for vigorous group
exercises meant to improve coordination
and responsiveness they learned to evoke
effects by staring at a cell phone and
imagining a conversation or speaking to
an empty chair in a classic
psychoanalytic exercise through a
heightened consciousness of the body and
renewed concentration on mundane objects
actors reformed emotions by refining
sensitivity to effect some have
described the process to me as one of
inhabiting one's life fully and honestly
even if it meant playing a role one
didn't like the structure of the class
reflected this of trajectory from
relaxation to reenergize ation and in
habitation but each participant in the
workshop traced their own path through
the techniques of effective reham body
meant manoir a Marid chain-smoking
journalist in her 30s never skipped a
day at the twice-weekly workshop she
began the course she said at a time when
she was psychologically tense and
confused I felt I wasn't living normally
either at work or at home she told me
the course appealed to her as a way to
quote make the personal dimension of my
life clearer her straightforward acting
style with few artistic flourish was
made it clear that Mara was acting for
herself but she did not see herself as
inhabiting her life more fully but the
workshop teaches you how to enter into a
role and separate yourself from it which
is necessary in everyday life she
explained it makes me more effective in
effect Marvel was learning to separate
her everyday performance as a role from
a deeper private self in an advanced
section of the workshop a young father
called neder likewise used acting as a
spaced apart from the routine of work at
his father's clothing factory he adapted
for years in amateur plays at his church
often playing what he called negative
characters such as a prejudiced man in a
play about AIDS but he liked about
theatre he told me was that you could
live more than one character at a time
while nethers own manner was soft-spoken
and shy his performances in the workshop
showed a special interest in the lives
of the mad
here he built upon his background in
church plays on social justice by
learning to embody characters who are
unable to live with their conscience
neither skillfully played the distraught
father of a rape victim and a bodyguard
driven mad by having failed to prevent
the assassination of a former president
so that his effective investment in
these rules clearly consisted of more
than pleasure at escaping his own
middle-class life the embodied in
dramatic form his troubled conscience as
a socially conscious Korean bourgeois
and gave him dramatic characters with
which to identify emotionally so now
there had taken the idea of embodying a
true self in the psychodrama curriculum
to embody an alter ego that signified
his trouble side and inhabiting the body
of this alter ego gave him a way of
bringing unruly effects into the
dialectics of drama at this example
among many shows the use of psychodrama
to engender therapeutic performances in
the acting workshop also produced
authentic renditions of the very
opposite of a balanced self such
negative dramatic characters were
attractive to workshop members and
indeed to viewers of several recent
Egyptian films as focal points for
discussing social dysfunction in a
neoliberal public sphere permeated with
discourse of self making and
entrepreneurial role models dysfunction
was similarly often individualized I
offer the example of these scenes from
the psycho drama workshop to highlight
an important aspect of the culture of
neoliberalism in Egypt that of negative
cultural icons that invited effective
identification both in therapy and in
cinema the participants in the psycho
drama workshop we might say channeled
their own negative effects to
constructing characters who were
socially dysfunctional but
psychologically comprehensible we might
see this is a process of counter
identification there anti-heroes stood
for a broken sense of self and held a
peculiar a lure for the respectable
young professionals who represented
their social opposite while it was
ironic that a therapeutic workshop
intended to help working people achieve
emotional balance generated such dark
psychological drama these did fit within
the tradition of socially conscious
theatre in Egypt so I read these
psychological dramas with in wider
generational politics of identity and
see how the workshop gives narratives to
intensely personal
ences that were both individually
therapeutic and symbolic of a rising
therapy culture which formed the visible
underside of self-help and personal
pedagogy and neoliberal Egypt and to
conclude some thoughts on performance
and citizenship yep you Jeff wrote in
his landmark work distinction that
bourgeois youths were inclined to try
own roles experiment with fashion trends
and generally to perform ownership of
cultural capital in anticipation of the
social roles they would assume as adults
but what happens to youthful performance
when social adulthood seems permanently
out of reach in what ways does
experimental performance become a means
of staging identity in more than
transitional terms the popularity of
theater as well as self-help performance
among Chiron's in their 20s and 30s
reveals that rehearsal can become a
means of embodied reflection on identity
formation for university students
unemployed graduates and young
professionals who made performance an
integral part of their lives rules were
often more satisfying than professional
identities or thwarted attempts at
marriage and financial independence
instead of introducing themselves as
business majors or law graduates
teachers or office workers many careens
of this generation instead spoke proudly
of their roles in plays and student
films or drama workshops in which they
post participated performance gave them
a perspective on their lives as
absurdist comedies self-help quests and
psychological dramas it also helped them
narrate life that did not fit within the
conventional narrative of a career I
believe that performance also worked as
a spatial metaphor of the embodied
practices by which these youth created
home-like spaces in the world the
theater was itself such a home hosting a
community of similarly alienated people
and fostering a common language
meanwhile personal development workshops
were more nurturing versions perhaps of
ineffective schools like that scene in
the play mother I want to be a
millionaire embodied performance in each
of these genres trace the outlines of
more habitable stories and spaces so I
argued that the decide dental decay tree
force of experimental performance as we
usually think of it takes a different
path here producing habitable dramas
alternatives to official myths of
consumerist youth glue to satellite
television and alienated from national
concerns in the context of an aging
dictatorship nepotistic distribution of
Economic Opportunity and surveillance by
the police state embodied performance
was a way for younger citizens to claim
space for their own history and our
right to act on January 25th thousands
of Koreans young and old including
activists unionized workers students and
professionals took to the city streets
for an extraordinary demonstration of
that right the icon of the movement that
started this revolution pileup side was
a young middle-class Alexandrian whose
death at the hands of police provided a
visceral example of the fate that many
in his generation feared the Facebook
page which launched the initial call for
protest mobilized his image to call for
an embodied action that rehearsed
political participation performative ly
and soon online networking combined
would labor an activist organization to
realize the mass movement that had
seemed like a utopian dream the part of
the Egyptian revolution revealed how
media and live networks were intertwined
in producing spaces and models of
participatory citizenship both left
aside for performative action rehearsing
an elocution reform what ineffective
political critique would resemble live
and mediated voices came together
poignant ly in a host of videos based on
footage of the revolutionary Street and
shared on social media and YouTube
I'm I frequency they don't tend to have
websites they tend to be very much
locally based and tier of them travel
though the little clips that I showed
were from a play that did actually
travel it went to the berliner
festspiele ER and traveled
internationally that's why the subtitles
just where I could share it with you and
as well as super titleist in general
these are very locally based productions
and when they're not it's interesting to
see how they adapt to to a more foreign
audience so the second day for example
is very visual in a way that the first
play was very very verbal which is why I
shared the more the dialogue than the
visuals of that one and yet the visuals
begin to complement of course you know
make up for the lack of language
comprehensibility or when these
translate but unfortunately no websites
good
yeah this is actually a crucial question
because what precisely these people were
fighting against was being categorized
as used and often being dismissed as
such for many years right so a
playwright or a director under 50 would
be called the young director the young
player and what that essentially meant
was that they lack structural power they
could no longer get a job at a state
theater and become a powerful director
of a state theater because they
definitely were no more jobs at state
theaters which had begun to cut their
budgets and of course there's there were
still you know the small nepotistic
crowd still in charge of these state
theater as well I shouldn't speak for
now had been until the last time I went
in charge of these state theaters some
of whom were the same age as these
people but to refer to them as youth so
of course that category has so many
connotations which I could go into one
of the recent amendments in the new
constitutional what the new
constitutional framework not the new
constitution itself is that the
president should be no younger than 40
and this was after many negotiations
where someone like Mohamed ElBaradei for
example said that I believe each appease
the president under 50 and live in
itself was highly controversial you know
how can we have an ngon octogenarian as
a president so that the politics of
youth here of course very much the
politics of an a giant across the
essentially which is also plutocracy and
all kinds of other aqua sees and
oligarchies
somebody there in some ways to say that
ever approximate term would be the
politician and younger generation yeah
except the term I use of my dissertation
title absolutely it is about
generational politics but of course
youth over here it does it is used very
broadly and I'm interested to see also
how it is used how people do appropriate
that term and try to turn it into a
positive in many ways as well right so
for example all the all the trade union
workers for example if participate in
the revolution still would commend the
youth who led the revolution and that's
of course at the complex term it
basically needs the activists not on a
fumar young but often use an activist
get that get merged together
so how can we see like if the youthful
responsible for such a major revolution
in Egypt so why do we say that the
president should be less than 50 years
old well it's a bit controversial
because there's so many years they had
been older people as politicians and
Mubarak of course was is in his 80s his
inner circle was similarly aged and of
course the supposed new generation that
he had in mind was his own son to take
over so you know it helps to be young if
yoga mal mubarak or one of his cronies
but other than that it was very much a
gerund chakra see people clinging on to
powers often happens with oligarchies
when power is highly centralized people
want to dole it out in little doses
those that are closest to them in this
kind of crony capitalist feudal system
so yes this was controversial because a
lot of people still today you know the
army High Command Council for instance
has members who will say things like oh
these youth don't have political
experience when they have been
organizing political events for 20 years
right that's about political of course
concept but
if you could talk a little bit about the
class end except this have cell phone
alienation in other it seems the group
the cobra that your brain that are
talking about is very much urban middle
class does this extend to worker just
another place to disagree Patrick well
my first answer would be yes it is
mostly urban and middle class and I was
fascinated by how diverse the urban
middle class is in its politics its
attitude towards neoliberalism and
towards activism but i did also study
workshops for example at one NGO in for
a part of town Darb al-ahmar where on
the one hand the South hub trainers were
training trainers I'm in a certain way
in this very kind of ethical way and the
other hand training these child workers
in a very aesthetic style on how to
behave essentially so the class
differences really showed up that I also
said in a workshop in Minya which is in
the south of Egypt at the jesuits school
and cultural center which kind of showed
you kind of the metropolitan provincial
dynamic of this movement but in general
it's very much middle class it's very
much d resonated I mean what fascinated
me was how aesthetics were so taken out
of self-help language you know but you
can be whoever you want to be doesn't
matter what you look like whether you
were headscarf etc etc was very very
intentionally aunty class aesthetic of
course it contains deeply within it
classes
hey there's one asking if you could say
a little more what you did touch on
about why this western reading of this
revolution of so-called new media or
Facebook revolution it is so so wrong
and that's obviously seen on tendencies
wale broadness in terms of what role of
media quick play in such event but it
short and catch all pays how well it's
the newest of the latest aspect of what
has been going on for 20 years or more
protests of course have been going on
for a very long time back in the 70s you
had the bread riots in 77 in Egypt even
before that you have very famous
professed singers who are still in vogue
today like shaky mom and such so there's
a long long tradition of activism in
Egypt and several of those who
participated in this revolution were all
leftist activists had been imprisoned
over the years for being activists and
some of their children are Abdel Fattah
hamona saved two of the major bloggers
and tweeters of the revolution where
children of activists who have been
imprisoned over the years so i think the
newest touch that was added was a medium
which was difficult to police so for
example I'll Abdel Fattah was one of
those that set up a VPN server which
blocked which went around censorship so
even well before the internet went
completely off for many years activists
were able to use that server in order to
do whatever they wanted to do and not be
shut down because the server was located
somewhere offshore essentially so it is
yeah it's just the newest h1 new thing
which they were able to do which you
could see if you wish as a tipping point
and with use that language if you like
that language or you could see it as
just the extending the edge of the
activist space but it was an important
extension in many ways and also
important means of networking in many
ways so yes of course it's not a
Facebook revolution but I don't think we
should discount the way in which media
and embodied action worked together here
to link different constituencies
essentially so this Facebook page we are
alternate side there's one in English
and one in Arabic and they both contain
updates from all kinds of constituencies
right so there's all this aggregate
whether on Twitter on Facebook of you
know protest at a union and they're
still going on now some of the major
protest still continuing in Egypt or at
the union's essentially all over the
country right say we have news of such
and such workers union and mahalo a
major textile mill town witches had
revolts for years strikes for years and
they bring the aggregate that into the
page so people can see what's happening
nationwide rather than having this very
local perspective on activism which
activists tend to have I was fascinated
by your description of the ways in which
your respiration of what performance
does in the sense that that is a in any
particular combination of the
therapeutic I guess called language
around performance and expectation of
what performance does whether in the
context of theater or the content to
sell out or psychotherapy it itself to
what extent do you see in a context that
what's been going on recently a
therapeutic language being applied also
to what political action does Food
Network's has an expectation for four
performances I think that you and I
should study when I go back at me
actually I don't know I mean I haven't
been back since sort of this got
underway but but yeah that's that would
absolutely be the question to ask I
think right in what ways the scene is
therapeutic but people just to give I
mean just initially my initial
impressions people have been using a
language of regaining dignity right
that's the kind of basic language of the
revolution which goes though I think
very much in with what they've been
saying all along but in terms of therapy
I think it's going to get interesting
once they start having the trial the
regime figures so on the fifth of march
i believe on the first set of major
trials of the interior minister Habib
el-adly and that's going to be a circus
so so that that could be a pointer which
to start that that's also a public
before
this is also a question of the various
areas i am but i wonder if you have set
aside looking over involved with the
sterilized accurate or therapy to some
health and performance pieces how they
actually related to us
lastly release I'd be not Richard
testing well I know a lot of them were
going down to the protest every single
day I would turn on al-jazeera and see
some of my friends on screen every now
and then head of the sowee who the first
person is clear i discussed has been an
activist for years and years and he's
been all over the newspapers now with
these protests and he's an interesting
figures he's not become a big movie star
since I did my research and everyone
recognizes him and he goes into the
protest with an overgrown shaggy beard
kind of against his not quite matinee
idol but film star look and now he's
back to playing the activist which is
which is interesting and all of them
have been participating at the self-help
crowd are well one of them yeah I did
not go yeah he did not go down to the
protest I guess yeah the self-help folks
are little more kind of bourgeois
mainstream and might not put their lives
on the line in the same way as in the
early days of the protest Nevada did the
protest just everyone was going down I
think to participate but yet that is
that is actually a distinction I noticed
prison